en france aujourd'hui il y aurait plus
de 30 millions d'utilisateurs de
portables et pour répondre à cette
demande croissante
les opérateurs ont installé des milliers
d'antennes relais permettant d'acheminer
ces nouvelles communications ses
antennes ont été plantés un peu partout
en haut des immeubles sur les arbres ou
encore sur des châteaux d'eau avec pour
ceux qui vivent à proximité l'inquiétude
de recevoir de mauvaises ondes et d'être
victime d'une véritable pollution
électromagnétique et laure y at il des
risques réels pour la santé difficile de
répondre catégoriquement les experts se
contredisent romuald venant valérie
lucas depuis un an madeleine istria est
en guerre avec france télécom expertise
procès pour tenter de débarrasser son
toit de cette antenne relais pour
téléphones portables
une présence que les copropriétaires de
l'immeuble elle comprise avaient
pourtant accepté en 97 contre un
dédommagement global de 360 milles
francs mais depuis elles s'inquiètent
après avoir entendu que les ondes
électromagnétiques émises par ces
systèmes pourraient peut-être se révéler
nocif pour sa santé regardez elle est là
dessus la ja mancelle en laye à mach aux
jeux si j'ai envie de venir voir un café
sur la terrasse je peux faire parce que
je suis soûl antennes dans la zone de
protection je pense qu on appelle ça
résonne fresnel quand j'invite nos
petits enfants ils sont là qui sont en
place ou l'antenne hommage hector c'est
tout de son côté france télécom n'a
toujours pas brancher les trois antennes
installées sur l'immeuble mais les
experts de l'opérateur sont formels les
tests en laboratoire montrent d'après
eux que les radiations sont inoffensives
va constater que au bout de quelques
dizaines de centimètres à mettre un
médecin quand on va être en dessous des
niveaux recommandés par la commission
européenne en cinq ans itinéris vous
telecom et sfr ont installé en france
environ 8000 en scène chacun une sous
les 300 mètres en ville et leur nombre
devrait encore grandir pour éviter la
saturation des réseaux succès du
téléphone portable oblige quelle est la
réalité du danger sur la santé humaine
les études scientifiques sont quasi
inexistantes pour l'instant et les
experts eux mêmes se contredisent les
craintes qu'ont les habitants de ces
immeubles ne sont pas fondées
scientifiquement aujourd'hui aucune
étude en laboratoire n'a montré qu'il
puisse y avoir un risque pour la santé à
cause d'eux il faut savoir que les
normes d'exposition des gens
actuellement sont au moins 50 fois au
dessus des noms pour lesquels un certain
nombre de spécialistes dont je fais
parti disent qu'il ya des étés pour la
population l'année dernière des
habitants des hlm du finistère s'étaient
plaints de troubles de santé à la suite
de la fosse d'une antenne des plaintes
relayée par la direction générale de la
santé dans une lettre adressée au
ministère du logement l'administration
affirmait qu'il ne peut être établi
qu'il n'existe aucun
perturbations hormonales cancers
leucémies
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
devrait donner les premières réponses en
2003 ce sera la fin d'une vaste enquête
de neuf années sur ce dossier